les etats unis qui mobilisent leurs
troupes dans la crise ukrainienne l'otan
déploie également des avions et des
bateaux pour renforcer la défense dans
la région la russie elle accuse les
occidentaux d'exacerber les tensions on
va rejoindre tout de suite à moscou
notre correspondant antoine gayraud
[Musique]
bonjour antoine on le voit l' escalade
militaire continue donc dans cette
région déjà sous très forte aux tensions
un
but magali tout à fait cet amoncellement
exponentielle d'équipements militaires
continuent en ukraine et dans les pays
orientaux membres de l'otan plusieurs
d'entre eux ainsi que les états unis ont
en effet annoncé renforcer leur aide
militaire à l'ukraine pour contrer ce
qu'ils estiment être un projet d'
invasion russe du pays par ailleurs vous
l'avez évoqué washington a annoncé avoir
placé jusqu'à 8500 militaires en état d'
alerte prêts à être déployés au sein des
troupes de l'otan écoutez
ce que nous demandons à ces unités c'est
d'être prêt à partir dans un délai plus
court que celui qu'elle avait on ne les
déployons pas maintenant nous ne disons
pas que la diplomatie est morte
ce serait irresponsable si l'on
considère les informations que nous
avons là bas il n'y a aucune attention
de la part des russes d'amorcer une
désescalade et étant donné qu'il faut du
temps pour que l'effort soit prêt à
partir dans un délai plus court il
serait irresponsable de ne pas penser à
s'assurer qu'elles le sont qu'elles ont
eu le temps pour se préparer et c'est
tout ce que nous faisons à ce stade
dans la journée d'hier le kremlin avait
d'ailleurs réagi en regrettant cette
escalade militaire en cours et
l'hystérie informationnel qui
l'entourent son porte-parole dit
également craindre que kiev se décide à
tenter de résoudre cette crise par la
force écoutez
en effet les autorités ukrainiennes
concentre énormément de force et de
moyens à la frontière avec la république
autoproclamée
sur la ligne de contact
en effet la nature de cette
concentration donne à penser que des
missions offensives sont en cours de
préparation
en effet une telle menace existe
actuellement
chaque arme qu'elle soit défensive ou
offensive est une motivation pour les
têtes brûlées de kiev de lancer cette
opération cela ne peut que nous
inquiéter nous en parlons depuis
longtemps et dans ce cas bien sûr nous
aimerions que les pays de l'otan dans
leurs nombreuses déclaration exhorte à
chaque fois qu hier à ne même pas pensé
à la possibilité de résoudre par la
force que free en ukraine
malgré cette concentration d'armement
des deux côtés de la frontière le
dialogue diplomatique n'est pas rompues
pour autant washington doit ces
prochains jours livrer une réponse
écrite à la russie concernant ses
demandes de garanties sécuritaires et en
europe également des initiatives sont
lancées pour tenter de mettre en oeuvre
une désescalade et on va en parler
justement merci beaucoup antoine pour
toutes ces précisions